[Music]
hi there guys my name's Blanco and this
is a little bit of a return to form for
me I haven't done a gaming impressions
video in a while but a company by the
name of lava boots sent me a free copy
of the early access title wild west and
wizards and yeah so I'm here to take a
look now here's the thing I'm a little
bit biased going into this because well
I love the concept an Old West based
game which we don't get a lot of anymore
mixed with a magic based RPG it sounds
like a good time so without further ado
let's take a look at these uh
spell-casting Cowboys
I love talking about graphics when it
comes to indie titles I really do
because it gives me a chance to talk
about art style and this game's art
style is uh yeah okay I'm not a big fan
of the art direction here I mean I get
it it's an indie title they're like
three people working on this game so
I'll cut them some slack frankly it's
not even so much the environments the
cartoon-like elements in the
environments are you know without
texture and honestly it's fine it
doesn't bother me in fact sometimes it
looks kind of nice my main issues with
the character design I'm not sure which
engine was used to render the characters
within this title they don't really seem
to fit the locales I almost wish they
had gone with less realistically
proportion characters this would help
differentiate this title from others as
well as give the title a sense of world
as it stands now the character models
are quite stiff on the character
selection screen as well as the
inventory screen my character looks like
he's scared to breathe and then every
once in while he'll wipe his face with
his clenched fist who does that on top
of all of that there is a very strange
choice in giving every character
including the NPC's a gun and now I know
this though Old West it's Western and
you know people have guns but come on
everyone
even the doctor like I'm pretty sure if
there were children in this game they'd
have guns too why does the doctor need a
gun yes it's all early access and for
that I deserve some forgiveness as the
developers take time to correct and
correct their vision but yeah it's it's
just odd I'm sure they always look like
this but for now they do and that's what
you'd be paying $15 for lastly I'll talk
about the UI the interface is pretty
generic from things like your health bar
to inventory nothing seems quite
appropriately themed yet I would love
for developers to add some western
themed borders to things like the skill
bar maybe even some different skill
icons I mean the Dodge skill is
literally a stickman but once again
things for the future pretty sure like
once they hire on like an artist or
something I don't know I don't know
you need for that I don't make games now
I know I seem harsh on this tighter than
honestly I think it's warranted not
because the game is bad but because I
think there's genuine potential here and
that shows in the gameplay at the end of
the day gameplay is king
so what we've got here well it's an FPS
one which for the life of me has almost
no business being won but I dig it
you start the game with a revolver and
as you progressed you gain access to
other guns rifles shotguns the works
what's more you were given two spells a
fireball and an ice spell so as you can
imagine the revolver sucks it's the
first gun it's supposed to suck there's
a nice feature within the title that
helps a little bit you can lock on the
targets which you know makes aiming
miles easier then free shooting because
the free shooting is is awful but that's
neither here nor there now you won't
always hit the targets even with the
lock-on this is because the enemies move
which is good but my favorite part of
the enemy AI is the fact they have to
reload as well you don't really see this
a lot I really like this gives you the
opportunity to do things like reload
recast a shield onto yourself or just
unload a clip aside from all of this the
game gives you what most RPGs give you
while it only has one class right now
the devs have made it clear that they
have plans for more there are things
like crafting side quests bounties NPCs
with varying levels of meaningful
dialogue the only thing that really irks
me is that the fact that the map doesn't
really tell you where the hell you are
at any given point and the map is pretty
darn big so not knowing where you are in
the middle of a desert is really bad as
things start to meld into each other the
map that you were given is a brown mass
in yen that that tells me nothing but
overall like I said I like it the fact
the game starts you off almost
immediately the dungeon and lore means
that there is definitely room here for a
dedicated fanbase mmm what more could
you want so all in all I really like
where the game is headed is it for every
RPG seeker no and that's perfect it
knows what it is and it runs with it
while there are a few odds and ends I'd
like to see smoothed out I will
definitely be one to return to this
title to see where the work
you know has gone so with that said if
you'll excuse me I gotta go raid some
bandit camps with my shotgun and book of
curses thanks for watching and stay
perfect
you
[Music]
you